welcome back today president trump
released a statement calling out his
successor for creating a quote
totally out of control situation at the
southern border
but president might still insist there's
no crisis now keep in mind since he took
office we've seen a flood of migrants
a crumbling border wall and kids filling
up containers
that's true but they don't want you to
hear about it especially from the man
who did it right we don't take our
advice or counsel
from former president trump on
immigration policy which was
not only uh inhumane but ineffective
over the last four years we're going to
chart our own path forward and that
includes treating children with humanity
and respect and ensuring they're safe
when they cross our borders
kaylee mackinnon is former white house
press secretary and a fox news analyst
kailey thank you so much welcome to fox
news primetime it's such a pleasure to
have you on today
i got to get your quick reaction uh
how's she doing so far as the press
secretary and
is that true was it a a terrible
situation when they came in the office
on the board guys she's got a heart yeah
she's got a hard job i wish her all the
best that's absolutely
inaccurate when biden came into office
you had a secure border
a system that was working where folks
were sent back to
their countries of origin and processed
in a way that was
expeditious that kept the american
people safe and now what you have
it's funny she wanted to talk about
humanity what you have is an absolutely
inhumane situation where according to
axios reporting
kids are being shoved down 100 capacity
facilities that should be at 50
capacity because of covet but they're
being shoved in there because there's
such a huge influx
coming in kids being trafficked when
they make this journey in the biden
administration incentivizing
this dangerous dangerous journey for
kids and for families
they broke up the agreement that you
guys have for
with with mexico so these people could
get an asylum
go through the legal process uh but yet
that wasn't asked from the podium
today what's your reaction that's right
i'm not surprised it's really
interesting to watch the nature of the
questions that the press
ask uh if it would have been the trump
administration we would have been
hammered on immigration throughout the
entirety of the briefing
you had of course great fox news uh
white house correspondent there asking
questions
to this end uh but by and large you know
you get questions about the color scheme
of air force one
how was biden enjoying the oval office
on his first day he's waited a long time
for it i think the american people are
are wise to the nature of the questions
but they deserve a press corps
that presses on issues like immigration
coveted relief
issues of importance to the american
people i want to get your reaction to
this from earlier today pelosi says
biden is the magic word look at this
in order to open these doors we do not
say
open sesame we say open
biden that's our magic word
i've been fighting i love it
i mean i want to laugh open bite
what is that that is that is quite
peculiar
uh very strange maniacal laugh there at
her own joke but what is what is really
comical when it comes to nancy pelosi is
every time she attempts
uh to relate to the american people it
always backfires from this open biden
anecdote that she put forward to
standing from in front of an ice cream
freezer during a pandemic with high high
class designer ice cream to
go into a salon when no one else in
california could and as you'll remember
maybe lawrence we played that clip on
loop at the white house press briefing
yeah i'm just curious what her magic
word was for donald trump
right right exactly right she was trying
to recount an anecdote there
uh with her grandchildren but i think it
backfired and left a lot of us just kind
of scratching her head
i got to ask you on this last one kamala
harris
talking to foreign leaders um
you know where is biden it's a great
question
especially when you consider the fact
that vice president pence yes you know
occasionally he would make a call to a
foreign leader
but president trump was the one making
the calls she's made i think three of
these calls so far
uh so maybe she is after all biden's a
liberal handler
or maybe she's trying to get well versed
in foreign policy because i do think
that she is the darling of the democrat
party at this moment and many see her as
the successor uh to president biden in a
future run for the presidency
i got to ask you this and you've since
left the trump administration of course
with the president leaving office and
enjoying the fox family but i i want to
know how these gaggles
work out because you know we saw a lot
of the former president when he was
president you can pretty much ask him
anything because he liked being out
there talking with the people
why don't you see the same thing
happening in this administration is it
because the president
is saying he doesn't want to do it or is
it because
his staff is shielding him from talking
to the people
it's undoubt it's undoubtedly the second
uh his handlers know
that he can't be trusted with the
microphone he can't engage with the
press that's why he has these short
little gaggles
uh but i will be very interested to
watch that press briefing that we were
promised today from joe biden by the end
of the month
i will be all eyes watching it closely
yeah i can't wait for that and hopefully
he doesn't need note cards
but we'll be watching thank you kaley
thanks lawrence